d je vais faire une bouillabaisse dans
un bain gérons celui qui tirera la carte
rouge celui qui tirera la carte rouge
devra faire le bain de boue y avait un
an
je joue avec vous nos cieux oui car je
viens d'acheter un beau rôle florennes
j'ai pas trop le tuer le salieri va être
dégueulasse et menée après c'est toi et
ta chance naked pas lié à côté de moi
attention c'est parti j'avais déjà dans
le bain attention attention on y va
ouais on va demander attention à l'eau
mélangée bien que j'aime et j'ai mélangé
je vous jure qu'il n'est pas tricher je
peux suivre et on croit alors alors vous
savez quoi nommé chacun vous allez tirer
même tenté d'étirer tous en même temps
d'accord on tire tous en même temps
attention voilà 2 3 vous ne regardez pas
non c'est toi c'est qu'il sait qu'ils
n'ont pas c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon
il reste 3e mais ça il en reste 3 il en
reste 3 donc je vais demander photos des
clips la villa il y en a il a quatre
points sont tout le monde a été sauvé
tu veux toi qui retire le toit non mais
tu es fou quoi il en reste quatre les
chéris on est qualifiés on va voir alors
moi je vois je pense franchement je vais
choisir la personne comme ça les deux
kelly et moi on va choisir les quatre
dernières cartes s'emballe pas d'accord
et moi c'est le break c'est correct
c'est quoi les autres vous êtes et pas
franchement n'ont cessé ces calories
ingérées de chance attention
3 2 1 il en reste à n'en resta
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors franchement moi je vous dit vous
êtes vous êtes ces deux chevaliers
servants maxime
ah oui mine de rien à temps karim moi je
moi non666 franchement est ce que vous
voulez vous vous porter candidat pour
sauver qui a dit ben ali dans quel sens
je veux bien sauver willy kanis élevé à
sa place le faire à sa place
ouais kelly écoute franchement je vais
te parler droit dans les yeux avec tout
ce qu'on a vécu
[Applaudissements]
alors là si j'avais reçu un chevalier
servant
je suis là pour toi
[Applaudissements]
il a dit qu'il allait aller maxime s'est
raidi vous merci
franchement le fait pas oui tu fais le
bad tu fait pas bouillir estiment les
matières au change
on est inquiète pas je te prêtre est
détruit c'est qu'elle n'avait pas gros
bisous à maxime oui et bien sympa
d'aller match entre mc clp à leur
effigie wii 2 dans sept buts à 1
[Musique]
ça va
allez on arrête tout les dégâts sont
avec tous les sommets